voici alexandre benalla l'homme qui
embarrasse l'elysée l'ancien conseiller
reconverti dans les affaires fait
désormais profil bas ils refusent de
témoigner face caméra mais il nous a
parlé pendant trois heures et nous a
autorisés à retranscrire ses propos
[Musique]
alexandre bédat c'est vraiment quelqu'un
qui est plein de paradoxes c'est à dire
que on a eu pendant des mois quelqu'un
de très fuyants qu'on a essayé de
solliciter au téléphone une multitude de
fois on avait plein de numéros de
téléphone il rappelait jamais etc
et puis des fois ils se mettent à nous
appeler un soir à 23h d'autres fois un
samedi matin à 8 heures et une espèce de
relation très bizarre où il disparaît
parfois pendant des semaines et puis
ensuite ils nous appellent plusieurs
fois dans la même journée il a commencé
à nous donner quelques rendez vous est à
chaque fois au dernier moment
c'est-à-dire qu'il nous envoie un
message pour dire voilà je peux voir
dans une demi heure c'est à prendre ou à
laisser c'était l'endroit de telle heure
et voilà donne ces rendez vous souvent
voire toujours au même endroit c'est
dans un dans un palace qui est à la 300
mètres de l'elysée et où aujourd'hui
alexandre bédat la passe la quasi
totalité de ces journées y en a obtenu
c'est de pouvoir discuter avec lui et
que l'on puisse retranscrire une partie
de ces trois heures d'entretien
un des épisodes qui a le plus intrigué
s'est produit dès les premières heures
de la sphère le 20 juillet dernier
c'est quand même l'histoire d'une
perquisition rocambolesque totalement
surréaliste les policiers arrivent enfin
l'après midi deux jours après les
révélations du monde le 20 juillet les
policiers arrivent avec un accent
benalla à son domicile
monsieur ban a dit qu'il n'a pas les
clefs et dit que c'est sa femme qui les
a et sa femme elle ne répond pas et
n'ont pas de bélier pour enfoncer la
porte
il appelle un serrurier le serrurier
vient il n'a pas le bon matériel pour
pour renforcer la porte
donc ce qui se passe c'est que la
première perquisition elle est ratée
c'est complètement incroyable c'est à
dire que on a aujourd'hui des policiers
qui nous disent ça n'existe pas si on
veut rentrer dans un domicile si on veut
faire une perquisition
on a tous les moyens d peslier des
serruriers enfin on peut rentrer dans un
domicile lendemain les policiers
arrivent enfin à ouvrir la porte
ils s'aperçoivent que le coffre-fort
d'alexandre benalla dont il avait été
prévu de l'existence puisque alexandre
viala on avait parlé lors de son édition
ce coffre fort disparu ils ne savent pas
où il est
alexandre reynal est interrogé par les
policiers et il dit oui bon c'est vrai
que j'ai demandé un copain de
transporter de le déplacer autre part je
sais pas qui l'a fait je ne sais pas où
il ya des versions qui sont complètement
contradictoire on a
des témoins qui nous explique que dans
ce coffre fort il y avait des documents
confidentiels notamment des documents
bancaires de la campagne électorale des
manuels macro et également des relevés
de banque delà de la première dame et on
a d'autres témoignages qui nous raconte
qu'en fait il n'y a rien de grave dans
ses coffres simplement des badges et des
pin's aujourd'hui la police n'a
auditionné aucun suspect n'a trouvé
aucune preuve que le coffre-fort et des
déplacés nous on s'est très vite
intéressé à un personnage qui s'appelle
chaufferie un crime qui est un soldat
d'élite c'est de 34 ans qui est un ami
d'alex morgan a et qui a été désigné par
certains médias comme étant l'auteur du
déménagement de ce coffre fort s'il
dément l'avoir déplacée
il reconnaît avoir vu le fameux coffre
que les enquêteurs cherchent partout
c'était l'été dernier dans l'appartement
parisien où alexandre benalla était
hébergée après sa garde à vue
effectivement dans le dos mais dans le
salon qui coffres vides qui est posée je
suis pas le seul à avoir rendu visite
comme c'est bizarre à chaque fois où
j'étais il était il n'était pas seul
la vie du monde des personnes issues de
son milieu professionnel de son
environnement
donc de l'elysée je pense que les
personnes qui sont passées ont dû voir
comme moi un coffre poser dans ce dans
ce sens aujourd'hui il parle parce
qu'ils estiment avoir été sacrifiée il
dit qu'il n'a pas déménagé le coffre
fort d'alexandre benalla et il est
persuadé que s'il a été pointé du doigt
et si son nom a été donné à la presse
c'est parce que l'on couvre les vrais
responsables qui sont des gens qui
occupent des postes qui sont plus
sensibles que le sien
il me dit que c'est chez mimi et je
comprends ensuite en rentrant je cette
personne que c'est une personne qui va
la communication laitiers proche d'eux
de l'elysée michel marchand c'est la
directrice d'une agence de photos qui
s'appelle best image et c'est quelqu'un
qui a fait beaucoup pour l'image people
du couple macron on sait qu'elle est
très proche de brigitte macron et elle a
aujourd'hui toujours à l'elysée ses
entrées et c'est quelqu'un qui est
extrêmement influente et qui joue un
grand rôle dans la communication de
crise notamment et on a découvert grâce
notamment aux témoignages de chokri au
crime que malgré le discours de façade
qui était de dire alexandre benalla n'a
plus rien à voir avec l'elysée ni de
près ni de loin
cette dame très proche du couple
présidentiel a en fait pris en charge
alexandre benalla et sa famille pendant
plusieurs jours chokri wakrim nous a
raconté que l avait mis à disposition
plusieurs véhicules
vous ne vous êtes jamais occupé ni
officiellement ni officieusement de
direction de ben ali lors de notre
rendez-vous alexandre benallal lui même
nous confirme cet épisode michel
marchand il me dit que mimi a sans doute
voulu faire plaisir à emmanuel macron
l'été dernier en le logeant en se disant
que peut-être le président de la
république serait content qu'elle donne
un coup de main à quelqu'un qui était
très proche à l'époque de du président
de la république et c'est vrai que ce
qui nous a intrigués avec
cette affaire de michel marchand c'est
l'énergie qu'elle a déployés à nier
quelque chose qui sur laquelle on avait
toutes les preuves comment alexandre
benalla a pu prendre le risque d'être
aussi proche des affaires du très
controversé mahmoud off alors qu'il
était encore en poste à l'elysée le
contrat russe pour faire simple c'est
l'histoire d'un contrat de sécurité qui
est passé entre la société de l'ami de
monsieur nana vincent kraz et un
oligarque russe qui s'appelle 'iskander'
mahmoud off et on prête
alexandre benalla un rôle d'entremetteur
ce contrat s'est négocié à 500 mètres de
l'elysée dans un bar à chicha et
plusieurs témoins nous raconte
qu'alexandre benalla était là qu'il a
donner des noms d'agents de sécurité qui
pourraient travailler sur ce contrat
l'elysée officiellement montre une
certaine sérénité
on nous explique que aucun problème que
tout est dans l'ordre et on a plusieurs
sources qui nous raconte que lorsque la
presse a révélé ce contrat russe
il ya eu un affolement total à l'elysée
par là même les services de
renseignements qui sont venus ce qu'on
dit et ce qu'on appelle dépoussiérer
c'est à dire qu'ils sont venus avec des
détecteurs de micros pour être certain
qu'il n'y avait pas de micro pas
d'émetteurs placé par des amis de
d'iskander mahmoud off ou d'autres
personnes qui auraient pu avoir accès à
l'elysée via benalla ça vous ne craignez
pas qu'alexandre benalla il peut être
utilisé par un service ce soir une
influence extérieure je ne l'espère pas
je ne le pense pas mais maintenant
toutes les vérifications sont en cours
il ya beaucoup aussi d' enquêtes qui
sont en cours et qui permettront de le
dire